RIGHT THE SENATE BUDGET
SUB-COMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE ON
CORRECTIONS, PUBLIC SAFETY,
JUDICIARY, LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION WILL COME TO
ORDER UH, GOOD MORNING. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITOL. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUB COMMITTEE TO
BE PRESENT IN ROOM 112 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND BEGIN
OUR HEARING. UH RIGHT NOW WE
WILL BEGIN AS A SUBCOMITTEE. A
SUBS SUB COMMITTEE. I GUESS,
RIGHT? UH, TODAY WE WILL COVER
ISSUES FROM THE COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ALL ITEMS AT
THE END OF THE HEARING, AND WE
ARE NOT TAKING ANY VOTES TODAY
TO ENSURE WE HAVE TIME FOR
EVERYTHING. ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
WE ARE ASKING PRESENTERS TO KEEP
THEIR TESTIMONY UNDER FIVE
MINUTES. I WOULD ALSO ASK MY
FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO KEEP
THEIR COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
CONCISE. UM DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS FROM OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS? UH SAYING NÓ COMMENTS
AT THIS MOMENT IN TIME? UM YOU
KNOW, I, I WILL AGAIN SKIP
QUORUM FOR THE TIME BEING, BUT
WE WILL BEGIN AGAIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. UM WE WILL BEGIN WITH
OUR FIRST ISSUE, WHICH IS THE
DEPARTMENT OVERVIEW AND SB TWO
IMPLEMENTATION. WE WILL HEAR
FROM MANY ALVAREZ, THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF POST YOU WILL HAVE
FIVE MINUTES IS MANNY HERE? ALL
RIGHT, UM, AND WE WILL BE
TIMING, FOLKS. THANK YOU. YOU
CAN BEGIN. HEY GOOD. GOOD
MORNING, CHURA. WE HAVE AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMITTEE AGAIN
. MY NAME IS MANNY ALVAREZ AND I
SERVE AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICER. STANDARDS AND
TRAINING. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THIS
MORNING. IS A REGULATORY
DEPARTMENT ESTABLISHED IN 1959
TO SET THE MINIMUM, UH MINIMUM
SELECTION AND TRAINING STANDARDS
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
IN CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY 609 LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THAT PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM. PARTICIPATION IS
VOLUNTARY. WITH THE INCREASED
CERTIFICATION RESPONSIBILITIES
ON POST SINCE THE PASSAGE OF SB
TWO. POST STAFFING MODEL HAS
INCREASED FROM 100 AND 36 TO 262
POSITIONS. AS OF TODAY, WE HAVE
100 AND 90 FULL TIME PERSONNEL
ON BOARD AND ESSENTIALLY 72% OF
FULL STAFFING. WE HAVE BROUGHT
ON BOARD 21 TEMPORARY RETIRED
ANNUITANTS TO HELP US WITH THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD AND
RETROACTIVE REPORTING CALLED FOR
IN S¼ B TWO. S¼ B TWO DIRECTLY
DEFINED SERIOUS MISCONDUCT BY
PEACE OFFICERS TO INCLUDE IN
GENERAL TERMS, NINE DISTINCT
DISQUALIFIERS. LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT
TO POST ANY COMPLAINT CHARGE OR
ALLEGATION OF SERIOUS MISCONDUCT
AS DEFINED WITH 10 DAYS. AS A
RESULT. WE WE'VE RECEIVED A
TOTAL OF 21,964 REPORTS IN YEAR
ONE. AND OF THOSE REPORTS,
APPROXIMATELY 70% WERE RELATED
TO THREE YEARS OF RETROACTIVE
REPORTING. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT ALTHOUGH THE
RETROACTIVE REPORTING OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT WAS MANDATED POST WAS
LIMITED TO ENFORCEMENT ACTION IN
ONLY THREE TYPES OF RETROACTIVE
MATTERS. DISHONESTY SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND THE USE OF DEADLY
FORCE LEADING TO DEATH OR
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY. FOR THE
REMAINDER OF MY TESTIMONY AND
FOR SIMPLICITY. I WILL INCLUDE
DATA RECEIVED AND ACTIONS TAKEN
FOR THE 15 MONTH PERIOD FROM
JANUARY. 1ST 2020 THREE TO MARCH
17TH 2024. DURING THIS PERIOD,
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
SUBMITTED 23,739 REPORTS OF
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT. RESULTING IN
16,427 CASES. WITH ALLEGATIONS
NAMING 15,000 THREE 178
INDIVIDUAL PEACE OFFICERS. OF
THE 16,427 CASES, 3885 REMAIN
UNDER INVESTIGATION BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. A TOTAL OF
6604 INVESTIGATIONS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
REVIEW OR ARE BEING INVESTIGATED
BY POST POST HAS RECEIVED AN
ADDITIONAL 565 COMPLAINTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. A TOTAL
OF 5788 CASES HAVE BEEN CLOSED
BY POST. AS A RESULT OF THE
REPORTING, WE HAVE ISSUED 100
AND 6 100 AND 16 IMMEDIATE
TEMPORARY SUSPENSIONS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE EITHER BEEN
CHARGED WITH A DISQUALIFYING
CRIMINAL VIOLATION OR WHO HAVE
RESIGNED OR RETIRED DURING AN
INVESTIGATION OF ALLEGED SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT. WE HAVE TAKEN ACTION
AGAINST 54 INDIVIDUALS FOR
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS. 13
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN NOTIFIED
OF POST INTENTION TO PERMANENTLY
REVOKE THEIR CERTIFICATION AND
OF THOSE 13 6 HAVE DEFAULTED ON
THEIR CERTIFICATION BY FAILING
TO APPEAL. A TOTAL OF SIX
INDIVIDUALS THUS FAR HAVE
REQUESTED A REVIEW AS DEFINED BY
STATUTE, ESSENTIALLY APPEALING
POST STAFFS INTENDED
DECERTIFICATION OR SUSPENSION
ACTION. A TOTAL OF 21
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ELECTED TO
VOLUNTARILY SURRENDER THEIR
CERTIFICATION AND ACTION WHICH
POST HAS THE SAME AN ACTION
WHICH HAS THE SAME EFFECT AS A
PERMANENT LIFETIME REVOCATION.
IN SUMMARY POST HAS CONDUCTED
205 FORMAL ACTIONS SINCE
JANUARY. 1 2020 THREE IN TERMS
OF NEW PEACE OFFICER
APPOINTMENTS, LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ARE NOW REQUIRED TO
QUERY POSTS FOR SEPARATION AND
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT DATA FOR
CANDIDATES WHO HAVE PREVIOUS
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICER
EXPERIENCE. AS A RESULT, POST
HAS RESPONDED TO 6876 REQUESTS
FOR INFORMATION FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SEEKING TO
HIRE PEACE OFFICERS. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK BEFORE
YOUR COMMITTEE. MADAM CHAIR. I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. WE'LL FIRST
GO TO L A Ó. SPIRIT WITH THE L
A Ó, UH, NÓ COMMENTS TO ADD,
BUT WERE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU. JOSHUA
WHITMER HOUSE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS? THANK YOU, UH,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR Dð RAZO. UM, ONE OF THE
ONE OF, UH, A PIECE OF
INFORMATION THAT YOU SHARED WITH
US. POST IS CURRENTLY ONLY
RECEIVING REPORTS FROM 379 OUT
OF 614 TOTAL COVERED AGENCIES.
COULD YOU SHED SOME LIGHT ON
THAT? WHAT? WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
SO, UM THOSE ARE AGENCIES WHO
HAVE HAD, UH ZERO REPORTS,
ESSENTIALLY OR MINIMAL REPORTS
IN OUR, UH AGENCIES ARE REQUIRED
TO SUBMIT AN ALLEGATION WITHIN
10 DAYS. WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
THREE 179 WHO HAVE SUBMITTED AT
LEAST ONE REPORT AND WE AT THE
END OF THE YEAR WE HAD 265 THAT
HAD ZERO REPORTS, UH, TO POST SO
, UM, WITH THOSE 265 THAT DID
NOT REPORT WE SENT LETTERS TO
EACH ONE OF THEM JUST TO ENSURE
THAT OUR DATA WAS ACCURATE THAT
THERE WAS NÓ REPORTING, THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE DEPARTMENTS
HAD LESS THAN 49 PEACE OFFICERS
AT THE WHICH YOU KNOW, SOME OF
THEM MAY MAY HAVE HAD FIVE PEACE
OFFICERS, SO THEY MAY NOT HAVE
HAD ANY SERIOUS MISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS. I GUESS. TO NOT GET
A REPORT IS DIFFERENT FROM IN A
REPORT WHERE THERE ARE NÓ UM, UH
, ALLEGATIONS RIGHT NÓ NÓ ISSUES
, SO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOT GETTING
REPORTS BECAUSE IT SAYS ONLY
RECEIVED REPORTS FROM THE THREE
179 AGENCIES CORRECT SO THEY
ONLY HAVE TO PROVIDE PART
POSITIVE, SO TO SPEAK, UM THEY
DON'T HAVE TO REPORT A NEGATIVE.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO REPORT TO US
THAT THEY HAVE NOTHING. THEY
ONLY HAVE TO REPORT WHEN THEY
HAVE AN ALLEGATION OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT OF THOSE 379 HAVE
REPORTED AT LEAST ONE ALLEGATION
OF SERIOUS MISCONDUCT, SOME OF
THEM UP TO 4000 ALLEGATIONS FOR
SOME OF THE BIG DEPARTMENTS AND
THEN 265 HAD ZERO. OK, SO NÓ
REPORTING EQUALS. NÓ INCIDENT.
THAT WE'RE AWARE OF. YES,
CORRECT, OK? UM I WOULD LIKE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CONSULTANT.
WOULD YOU'D LIKE TO SENATOR
WAHAN HERE. SENATOR DIAZO
SENATOR NEWMAN, SENATOR SARTO. A
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED. THANK
YOU. QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
. WE WILL CONTINUE WITH
QUESTIONS. UM, I DO ACTUALLY
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR YOU, UH,
IN PARTICULAR WITH, YOU KNOW, S¼
B TWO THAT OBVIOUSLY HAS KIND OF
CHANGED A LOT OF THINGS. UM IF
AN OFFICER THIS IS MORE OF A
TECHNICAL QUESTION IF AN OFFICER
WERE TO BE UNDER INVESTIGATION
IN, LET'S SAY A CITY AND DECIDES
TO QUIT THAT CITY AND MOVE ON TO
ANOTHER CITY. WHAT HAPPENS? SO
IF AN OFFICER LEAVES UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES, AND THEY ARE
UNDER INVESTIGATION FOR AN
ALLEGATION OF SERIOUS MISCONDUCT
, WE ARE ALLOWED BY STATUTE BY
S¼ B TWO TO ISSUE AN IMMEDIATE
TEMPORARY SUSPENSION, AND THAT'S
WHAT I REFERENCE THAT WE'VE
ISSUED 116 OF THOSE SO THAT
INDIVIDUAL CAN NÓ LONGER WORK AS
A PEACE OFFICER UNTIL IT'S
RESOLVED. IT'S NOT A PUNISHMENT
OF ANY, UH, BY ANY SORTS. IT
REALLY IS TO PUT A HOLD ON THAT
INDIVIDUAL. SO THERE'S SOME
RESOLUTION. WE CAN ISSUE IT FOR
A CRIMINAL CHARGE. WHEN SOMEBODY
HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH A CRIME
THAT WILL BE A DISQUALIFIER WHEN
THEY HAVE RESIGNED OR RETIRED IN
LIEU OF AN INVESTIGATION FOR
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT, AND WE DO
ISSUE THOSE REGULARLY AS A HOLD
UNTIL WE RESOLVE OR THAT
INDIVIDUAL RESOLVES THEIR
CRIMINAL CHARGES SO THEY CAN'T
GO WORK ANYWHERE ELSE. OK SO
JUST SERVING ON LOCAL CITY
COUNCIL, UM THIS WAS A PATTERN
THAT I SAW PRETTY REGULARLY
WHERE AN OFFICER CHOOSES. TO
RESIGN AND MOVE INTO A DIFFERENT
CITY. UM AND I THINK THAT THERE
IS A LACK OF UNDERSTANDING
AMONGST CITIES AS TO WHAT THEIR
ENFORCEMENT CAPABILITY IS NUMBER
ONE, AND IT'S NOT JUST THE
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA, OF COURSE,
RIGHT, BUT WHEN AN OFFICER
DECIDES TO MOVE TO A DIFFERENT
STATE, UM WE HAVE SEEN THIS. I
HAVE PERSONALLY SEEN THIS WHERE,
UM MANY OF THE LAWSUITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS IT'S COMPLETELY
ON HOLD. THEY CAN'T FORCE THE TO
COME. THEY THEY HAVE NÓ POWER.
NÓ SAY, NÓ NOTHING. UH SO IN IN
THAT REGARD, WHAT ARE THE
OPTIONS? WHAT'S THE CASE? WELL
FOR US ONCE WE ISSUE THOSE
ORDERS, AND WE DO THEM
REGULARLY, AND WE JUST DID ONE
THIS WEEK. UM WE LIST THAT
INDIVIDUAL ON OUR WEBSITE. WE
SEND NOTIFICATION TO THE Dð A TO
THE TO THE INDIVIDUAL AS WELL AS
TO THE LAST DEPARTMENT THAT THEY
WORKED OUT OVER THE MISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS OCCURRED AND THEY
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. COULD THEY GO TO
ANOTHER STATE? IT'S UP TO THAT.
STATE AS TO WHETHER THEY'RE
GOING TO ALLOW THAT PERSON TO
WORK. GENERALLY, THEY DON'T BUT
IN THEORY THEY COULD, BUT IN
CALIFORNIA THEY COULDN'T GO FROM
, YOU KNOW, A BAY AREA
DEPARTMENT TO A DEPARTMENT IN L
A COUNTY AND WORK YOU GUYS
COMMUNICATE WITH OTHER STATES.
WE DO ON A FAIRLY REGULAR BASIS.
AND THEN UM, WE ALSO WHEN
THERE'S A PERMANENT REVOCATION
OR A CRIMINAL CONVICTION, WE
SUPPLY THE DATA TO THE NATIONAL
DECERTIFICATION INDEX, WHICH IS
ALSO REQUIRED UNDER SENATE BILL
TWO, AND WE WORK WITH OTHER
STATES ON A REGULAR BASIS. UM,
AND WE JUST HAD ALL THE WESTERN
STATES THAT POST IT'S UH, IT'S A
IT'S A GOOD COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIP, BUT YET IT IT
DEPENDS ON EACH STATE AS TO
WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO ALLOW
THIS INDIVIDUAL TO GO WORK IN
THEIR STATE. WHAT IF THE
INDIVIDUAL IS NOT COMPLYING WITH
THE INVESTIGATION? SO ONE OF THE
DISQUALIFIERS IS FAILURE TO
COOPER WITH AN INVESTIGATION AND
IT'S BOTH FAILURE TO COOPER WITH
INVESTIGATION AT THE DEPARTMENT
AND ITS FAILURE TO COOPER WITH
AN INVESTIGATION AT POST THAT IS
ONE OF THE NINE DISQUALIFIERS.
IF THEY FAIL TO COOPER, THEY CAN
EITHER BE PERMANENTLY
DECERTIFIED. OR THEY CAN BE THE
SUBJECT OF A TEMPORARY
SUSPENSION TILL WE KIND OF
RESOLVE THE SITUATION. OK, AND
YOU HAVE AN 18 MEMBER TASK
FORCE. WHAT IF THEY ALL ARE LIKE
5050 SPLIT? SO THAT THERE
THERE'S TWO THERE'S A BOARD
WHICH, UH, IS MADE UP OF NINE
INDIVIDUALS, AND THAT IS A
RECENT BOARD THAT'S BEEN
COMPRISED BY SENATE BILL TWO.
THEY HAVE A 51% VOTE TO PASS.
UH, SOMETHING THROUGH FOR A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE COMMISSION
. THE COMMISSION HAS A
REQUIREMENT OF A TWO THIRDS VOTE
MAJORITY VOTE, SO IT'S MORE THAN
50. SO IF IT'S NOT PASSED BY TWO
THIRDS. THEN IT DIES. OK AND
THEN WHAT? WHAT IS THE MAKEUP OF
THESE MEMBERS? OR ARE THEY ALL
FORMER PEACE OFFICERS? THEY ARE
NOT THE BOARD. THE NEW BOARD IS
MADE UP OF NINE INDIVIDUALS. UH,
TWO OF THEM ARE, UH LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR CURRENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SEVEN ARE NOT.
UM MOST OF THEM ARE PUBLIC
MEMBERS. ADVOCATES UH, AN
ATTORNEY POSITION. SEVEN OF
THOSE MEMBERS ARE APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR AND TWO BY THE
LEGISLATURE. IN TERMS OF THE
COMMISSION. IT'S 18 MEMBERS. UH,
PROB. THERE'S I BELIEVE FOUR
PUBLIC MEMBERS OF THE 18 THAT
ARE NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT. THERE'S
TWO PUBLIC. THERE'S FOUR PUBLIC
MEMBERS TO THAT ARE APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR TO THAT ARE
APPOINTED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THEN THERE'S SOME OTHER
POSITIONS FOR AN EDUCATOR FOR A
CITY ELECTED, UH, CITY
ADMINISTRATOR, A COUNTY ELECTED
COUNTY, WHICH CAN BE NON LAW
ENFORCEMENT, SO THERE'S YOU KNOW
, SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SIX AND
SEVEN POTENTIAL NON PEACE
OFFICERS ON THE COMMISSION OF
18. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS? NÓ NÓ. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. WE MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO. CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE UTILIZATION, REVIEW
AND EVALUATION SYSTEM FEE
INCREASE. WE'RE GOING TO FIRST
HEAR FROM THE Dð Ó J. YOU HAVE
FIVE MINUTES. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS ASHLEY
HART, BUDGET OFFICER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. UM, FOR THIS ITEM, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
REQUESTS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO IMPLEMENT A LICENSE FEE
INCREASE FROM $9 TO $15 TO
SUPPORT CONTINUED OPERATION OF
THE MANDATED CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE UTILIZATION REVIEW AND
EVALUATION SYSTEM. UM, WE CALL
IT THE CURES SYSTEM. THE FEE
INCREASE IS REQUIRED DUE TO A
RECENT REDUCTION IN THE FEE FROM
$11 TO $9, WHICH TOOK EFFECT IN
APRIL. 2023 COMBINED WITH
INCREASING TECHNOLOGY, VENDOR
COSTS AND STANDARD OPERATIONAL
COST INCREASES. THE REQUESTED
FEE INCREASE WILL SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT'S EXPENDITURES,
INCLUDING PERSONAL SERVICES,
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND
SUPPORTING OPERATIONAL EXPENSES
TO MAINTAIN AND OPERATE THE
SYSTEM. THE Dð, Ó J AND Dð èC
TEAMS ARE AVAILABLE THIS MORNING
TO SPEAK TO ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE ON THIS PROPOSAL.
DO WE HAVE THE L A Ó? NOTHING
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING. ALL RIGHT. UM, DO WE
HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE? YOU WILLING TO ASK A
QUESTION? WE SEE NOTHING. I HAVE
A QUICK QUESTION IN WHAT IS THE
Dð Ó J? UH WHAT HAS THE Dð Ó J
DONE TO REDUCE AND MINIMIZE ITS
COST RELATED TO MAINTAINING
CURES? SO Dð Ó J HAS
EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT COST
INCREASES FROM THE VENDORS
RELATED TO THE SOFTWARE THAT'S
REQUIRED AND THE MAINTENANCE OF
THE SYSTEM. UM ALSO OVER THE
YEARS, COSTS HAVE ACTUALLY GONE
UP A BIT DUE TO, UM, EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION INCREASES AND
PRIMARILY THOSE VENDOR COST
INCREASES THAT I MENTIONED. ALL
RIGHT, UM, IS THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS RE REGISTERING AND
PAYING THE FEE SOMEWHAT STABLE.
I THINK Dð èC IS HERE TO SPEAK
TO ANY QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
REGISTRATION VOLUMES. AND WE
HAVE TAYLOR HERE FROM Dð èC, A
MORNING. MY NAME IS TAYLOR SHI
AND I'M, THE CHIEF FISCAL
OFFICER FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. I WOULD SAY
THAT THE LICENSEE POPULATION
THAT PAYS THE CURS FEE IS STABLE
. IT IS GROWING SLIGHTLY, AS ARE
NORMAL LICENSEE POPULATIONS ARE
GROWING. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
SEEING NÓ OTHER QUESTIONS. WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
DEPARTMENT OVERVIEW WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR FROM CHRIS RYAN, THE
CHIEF OPERATIONS OF THE Dð Ó J.
UM, YOU WILL HAVE FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM.
CHAIR CHRIS RYAN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. CHIEF OF
THE DIVISION OF OPERATIONS. I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND THE
MEMBERS FOR OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT OUR BUDGET ISSUES TODAY.
UM, AS YOU SAID, I'LL BE
PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. AND
THEN ASHLEY HARP. OUR BUDGET
OFFICER IS HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY OF OUR
BUDGET PROPOSALS. UM, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUST THIS IS
PRIMARILY MADE UP INTO FOUR
PROGRAM AREAS. THE LEGAL
SERVICES DIVISION, THE DIVISION
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT, CALIFORNIA
JUSTICE INFORMATION SERVICES
DIVISION AND THE ADMINISTRATION
ARE DIRECTORATE. UM, THE
DEPARTMENT IS PROPOSED BUDGET IS
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT THREE
BILLION AND WHICH IS A 4%
REDUCTION FROM A CURRENT YEAR.
RESOURCES AVAILABLE.
APPROXIMATELY 38% OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET IS GENERAL
FUND, AND THERE ARE 35 SEPARATE
FUND SOURCES THAT PROVIDE THE
REMAINDER OF OUR BUDGET. THE
PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES
APPROXIMATELY 5900 POSITIONS
ACROSS STATE, UH ACROSS THE
STATE, UH IN OFFICE BUILDINGS
LABS TASK FORCES, UH, AND OTHER
VENUES FROM SAN DIEGO TO THE
OREGON BORDER. UH, THE LEGAL
SERVICES DIVISION IS MADE UP OF
THE OFFICE OF GENERAL COUNSEL,
THE CIVIL LAW, PUBLIC RIGHTS
CRIMINAL AND THE MEDICAL FRAUD
AND ELDER ABUSE DIVISIONS.
BRIEFLY THE MEDI FRAUD DIVISION
IS CHARGED TO INVESTIGATE AND
PROSECUTE THOSE WHO WOULD
DEFRAUD TAXPAYERS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND DIVERT SCARCE HEALTH
CARE. IS FROM THE NEEDY. THE
DIVISION OF MEDICAL FRAUD AND
ELDER ABUSE ALSO WORKS
AGGRESSIVELY TO PROTECT
RESIDENTS IN NURSING HOMES AND
OTHER LONG-TERM CARE FACILITIES
FROM ABUSE AND NEGLECT. THE
CIVIL DIVISION IS MADE UP OF
ATTORNEYS CHARGED WITH
PROTECTING AND ENFORCING
CALIFORNIA'S, UM STATE AGENCIES,
PRIMARILY DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS, AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. ARE THERE TWO
LARGEST CLIENTS. THE PUBLIC
RIGHTS DIVISION IS CHARGED WITH
PROTECTING AND ENFORCING
CALIFORNIA STATUTES RELATED TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION. ANTITRUST
HEALTH CARE. THE ENVIRONMENT AND
MANY OTHER PUBLIC INTEREST
STATUTES. THE CRIM DIVISION
PRIMARILY FOCUSES ON CRIMINAL
LAW AND APPEALS IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM, AND THE OFFICE
OF GENERAL COUNSEL IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SUPERVISING AND
COORDINATING INTERNAL LEGAL
WORK. CALIFORNIA JUSTICE
INFORMATION SERVICES DIVISION IS
PRIMARILY MADE UP OF OUR
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA PROVIDING CRIMINAL
HISTORY. UH, AND INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY, UH, DATA. THE
DIVISION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AS
IT SOUNDS, IS OUR, UH, PUBLIC
SAFETY LAW ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
AND WORKS WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO
THAT'S OUR OVERVIEW FOR TODAY,
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON OUR B èC P
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU. NOTHING.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
NOTHING UM, I DO JUST WANT TO
ASK. HOW IS THE Dð Ó J
CONTRIBUTING TO REDUCING THE
BUDGET DEFICIT THEN? SO WE HAVE
AN ITEM ON THE AGENDA THAT WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT. LATER THE
LITIGATION DEPOSIT FUND. THERE
WAS A PROPOSAL LAST YEAR FOR
TRANSFERRING LOANING 400 MILLION
. UH AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES $100 MILLION LOAN. UH,
BOTH OF THOSE TOGETHER ARE BEING
TRANSFERRED TO THE GENERAL FUND
AS I UNDERSTAND IT, BUT I WOULD
DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR A FEW FURTHER
DETAILS ON THOSE PROPOSALS. ALL
RIGHT. I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU. UM WE CAN MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR, WHICH IS ARMED AND
PROHIBITED. PERSONS UPDATE.
WE'RE GOING TO FIRST HEAR FROM
MICHAEL REDDING, SPECIAL
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL AT
THE Dð Ó J. MICHAEL, YOU WILL
HAVE FIVE MINUTES. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING.
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE. UH
AGAIN. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
REDDING. I'M A SPECIAL ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
. BESIDE ME IS PETER WOLD,
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR THE
BUREAU OF FIREARMS. UH, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE RECENTLY
RELEASED ITS 2023 APPS REPORT. I
PROVIDED A HANDOUT. UH WHICH
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE ALL RECEIVED
AND SHOULD BE IN FRONT OF YOU.
I'M GONNA BRIEFLY GO OVER THE
NUMBERS FROM LAST YEAR JUST TO
GIVE YOU AN UPDATE. UM AND THEN.
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN I
WELCOME YOUR QUESTIONS. ON THE
FIRST PAGE, AND EVERYTHING'S
NUMBERED AT THE TOP SO YOU CAN
FOLLOW ALONG. THIS SHOWS THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF FIREARM OWNERS
IN THE STATE AS YOU CAN SEE, IT
GOES UP JUST A LITTLE BIT EVERY
YEAR LAST YEAR WAS ABOUT 3.5
MILLION, TURNING TO THE SECOND
PAGE. THIS IS THE YEARLY
REMOVALS AND ADDITIONS FROM THE
APPS LIST. AS OF JANUARY 1ST OF
EACH YEAR. UM, AS YOU CAN SEE
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS,
REMOVALS HAVE OUTSTRIPPED
ADDITIONS. MEANING WE'RE WE'RE
MORE PEOPLE ARE COMING OFF THE
APPS LIST OR BEING ADDED, UH,
THE RESULTS OF THAT ARE SHOWN ON
PAGE THREE. SO WE REACHED A HIGH
WATER MARK OF ABOUT 24,005 09 IN
2022, AND NOW WE'RE DOWN TO 20
THREE 1004 151. AT Dð Ó. J
CAN'T TAKE ALL OF THE CREDIT FOR
THAT. UM BUT IF YOU LOOK ON PAGE
FOUR THAT SHOWS ON THE RIGHT
SIDE THERE, THE INVESTIGATION
CONTACTS AND THE APPS
INVESTIGATIONS CLOSED YEAR OVER
YEAR FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS,
AND AS YOU CAN SEE BOTH
INVESTIGATION, CONTACTS AND
INVESTIGATIONS CLOSE HAVE BEEN
INCREASING. THAT SAID, IF YOU
LOOK ON THE LEFT SIDE OF THE
PAGE, UH, YOU'LL SEE THAT THE
NUMBER OF PROHIBITED OR THAT ARE
REMOVED AS A BREAKDOWN IS ABOUT
3500 ARE BECAUSE THEY'RE
DISSOCIATED FROM ALL THEIR
FIREARMS AND ABOUT 50. THREE 100
ARE BECAUSE THEY FALL OFF
BECAUSE THEY'RE NÓ LONGER.
PROHIBITED AND TURNING TO THE
LAST CHART. UH, THIS IS THE
BREAKDOWN OF THE PENDING
CATEGORY PENDING CATEGORY IS, UH
, IS THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE A REGISTERED OR ON THE
PROHIBITED PERSONS LIST. UM BUT
FOR SOME REASON, WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO TAKE THEIR FIREARM
USUALLY BECAUSE WE'VE TRIED TO
CONTACT THEM THREE OR MORE TIMES
UNSUCCESSFULLY BECAUSE THEY
INDICATE THAT THEY TRADED THE
FIREARM. GOT RID OF THE FIREARM.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, UH, BUT
HAVE NÓ PROOF OF THAT, UM, THAT
THAT NUMBER REMAINS AT ABOUT
15,000 EACH YEAR, SO THE TOTAL
IS JUST UNDER 24,000 FOR
PROHIBITED INDIVIDUALS ON THE
PROHIBITED PERSONS LIST, 15,000.
PENDING CATEGORY AND THEN ABOUT
EIGHT OR 9000 ARE ADDED ON AND
REMOVED, UM EACH YEAR SO YOU CAN
SEE THE VAST MAJORITY. THERE ARE
UH, PROHIBITED BECAUSE OF A
FELONY CONVICTION. UH AND THEN,
FINALLY, JUST TO TURN BRIEFLY TO
THE RECOMMENDATIONS, TWO MAJOR
BUCKETS OR EXCUSE ME. UM THE
FIRST IS REALLY, UM SHIFTING
MORE OF THE WORK ON THE FRONT
END PEOPLE WHO HAVE THEIR
FIREARM REMOVED FROM THEM AT THE
TIME OF CONVICTION AT THE TIME
THAT A RESTRAINING ORDER ISSUED
THOSE PEOPLE DON'T END UP IN THE
APP SYSTEM. OBVIOUSLY THAT'S THE
BEST TIME TO DO IT FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY PURPOSES, AND THAT'S THE
BEST TIME TO DO IT BECAUSE IT'S
NEAREST IN TIME TO THE
PROHIBITION. UH, WE'VE HAD SOME
GREAT SUCCESSES OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS WITH THAT, UM, I'VE
LISTED HERE, UH, A FEW OF THE
BILLS THAT THAT YOU ALL HAVE
PASSED, UH, WHICH HAVE
EFFECTIVELY HELPED THAT BOTH
POLICY BILLS AND SOME, UH,
BUDGET ADDITIONS SPECIFICALLY TO
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL, UH, TO
WORK ON FIREARM RELINQUISHMENT
ON THE FRONT END. AND THEN THE
SECOND BUCKET. UM IS REALLY SOME
WORK. UH, THAT WE'RE DOING AT Dð
Ó J. ONE IS MOVING TOWARD
COMPETITIVE SALARIES WITHIN THE
BUREAU OF FIREARMS. THIS IS AN
ONGOING ISSUE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
. UH AGENTS, UH, DON'T RECEIVE
COMPETITIVE PAY, SO WE'RE, UH,
OFTEN LOSING THEM RETRAINING AND
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
HIRING ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS,
UH, AND THEN FINALLY MODERNIZING
THE APPS DATABASE AND AGAIN.
THIS IS A PROJECT THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY ENGAGED IN. UM AND WE
ARE IN TWO OF THE FOUR PART UH,
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY PROPOSAL. APS IS THE
FIRST SYSTEM OF ITS KIND IN THE
COUNTRY. IT'S ALSO THE FIRST
SYSTEM OF ITS KIND TO BECOME
OUTDATED. SO WE'RE WORKING TO
UPDATE THAT. SO THE SYSTEMS ALL
TALK TO EACH OTHER. UM AND WE
CAN MORE QUICKLY, UH, PULL
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PROHIBITED
AND RETRIEVE THEIR FIREARMS. UM,
WITH THAT, I WELCOME YOUR
QUESTIONS. UH L Ó DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ALL RIGHT, UH, MEMBERS,
UH, SENATOR AND A COUPLE QUICK
QUESTIONS, I GUESS FIRST. UM, IF
YOU LOOK AT YOUR TOP SLIDE, UH,
THAT'S AN IMPRESSIVELY STEEP
CURVE. WHAT ACCOUNTS FOR WHAT?
IN 15 YEARS, MORE THAN TRIPLING
THE NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE KNOWN TO HAVE FARMS. IS IT
JUST BETTER RECORDKEEPING OR IS
IT THE CHANGES IN BEHAVIOR? IT'S
A FEW DIFFERENT THINGS. SO UH,
BEFORE 2014, THE DEPARTMENT
DIDN'T TRACK UH, LONG GUNS. SO
WE DID SEE ANY TIME YOU PURCHASE
A LONG GUN. UM, AFTER THAT DATE
THAT'S GONNA BE ADDED, UH BEFORE
. I CAN'T REMEMBER THE YEAR BUT
BUT SOME POINT EARLIER, WE
WEREN'T TRACKING, UH, HANDGUNS.
SO, UH, YOU KNOW, NEW
ADDITIONAL. THIS WOULD BE
INCLUDED THERE, SO SOME OF IT IS
THAT SOME OF IT IS BETTER
RECORDKEEPING, MAKING SURE THAT
ALL FIREARM TRANSFERS GO THROUGH
A FIREARMS DEALER. ANYBODY WHO
COMES INTO THE STATE BUT THEN
THE OTHER PART OF IT IS YEAH IS
MORE PEOPLE BUYING FIREARMS?
OBVIOUSLY DURING THE PANDEMIC,
THERE WAS A SHARP INCREASE IN,
UH INDIVIDUALS PURCHASING
FIREARMS, AND THAT'S REFLECTED
ON HERE AND AS YOUR DOES YOUR
DATA ALSO REFLECT THE NUMBER OF
FIREARMS OWNED BY INDIVIDUALS.
THIS DOES NOT REFLECT THE NUMBER
OF FIREARMS ON IT. BUT DO YOU
TRACK IT? WE DO. UM AND LOOKING
AT THE YEARLY REMOVALS AND
ADDITIONS. WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
AVERAGE DURATION OF STAY FOR
SOMEBODY ON THE APPS LIST? AND
WHAT ARE THE TRIGGERS OR
CONDITIONS TO ALLOW THEM OFTEN.
I DON'T THINK THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
TRACK THE AVERAGE YEARLY. STAY
AGAIN WITH THE OUTDATED SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE, UH WHAT? WHAT I
CAN SAY IS THAT WE'RE WE'RE
WORKING ON INDIVIDUALS WHO WHO
COME INTO THE SYSTEM AND ARE
TRYING TO DISSOCIATE THEM FROM
FROM THEIR FIREARMS. SO UH, UH.
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WALD AND HIS
TEAM ARE GOING OUT AND DOING
OFTEN APP SWEEPS. UH, SO THEY'LL
IDENTIFY A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
IN A GIVEN AREA AND THEY GO AND
KNOCK ON THE DOOR. DO YOU STILL
HAVE THIS FIREARM AND ULTIMATELY
GO THROUGH? PROCESS OF TRYING TO
RETRIEVE THAT FIREARM FROM THEM.
IT'S DIFFICULT BOTH BECAUSE IT'S
DANGEROUS WORK. UM AND ALSO
BECAUSE BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF
THE LIST, THESE ARE NOT HOT,
MEANING SOMEBODY DIDN'T JUST GET
PROHIBITED. AND WE KNOW THEY'VE
GOT A GUN. WE'RE A FEW MONTHS
LATER. BY THE TIME IT MAKES THE
INFORMATION MAKES ITS WAY TO US,
SO WE CAN'T USUALLY GET A
WARRANT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
FRESH INFORMATION. WE TRY AND
DEVELOP IT, BUT THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
A LONGER PROCESS. UH, BUT SO
THAT'S THAT'S HOW WE'RE WORKING
TO. PEOPLE OFF OF THE LIST. AND
I THINK, LASTLY FOR ME, I, I
THINK YOU'VE GIVEN ME PART OF
THE ANSWER IF YOU LOOK AT AT THE
PENDING APPS CASES, YOUR PIPES
ARE HERE, WHICH LOSES A LITTLE
SOMETHING IN BLACK AND WHITE. UH
BUT, UH, WHAT WOULD YOU NEED,
UH, TO CLEAR MORE PENDING CASES
MORE QUICKLY. SO THE PENDING
CASE IS ALWAYS ALWAYS A TRICKY
ONE. IT'S THE HARD PART IS THESE
ARE PEOPLE THAT WE'VE WE HAVE
INVESTIGATED AND THE WAY THAT I
WOULD SAY IT IS THAT IT'S WE
WANT. WE WANT THIS INFORMATION
AND WE WANT TO KNOW THAT THESE
PEOPLE WERE NOT GOING TO TAKE
THEM OFF THE LIST BECAUSE
SOMEBODY SAYS, HEY, I TRADED A
FIREARM. UH AND I DON'T HAVE THE
PAPERWORK FOR IT. BUT WE REALLY
WANT TO FOCUS ON THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAY STILL HAVE A FIREARM. SO
THE PENDING LIST IS ALWAYS, YOU
KNOW, A LITTLE BIT OF A MONKEY
ON OUR BACK. UM THE FOCUS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO TRY AND
GET PEOPLE AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN
BEFORE THEY MOVE BEFORE THEY
TRADE THE FIREARM BEFORE
ANYTHING ELSE HAPPENS AND WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT IN THE LONG TERM
THAT'S GOING TO REDUCE THE PEN.
LIST I GUESS. ONE LAST QUESTION.
SORRY UM, YOU KNOW, BIG STATE.
UH WHERE ARE WHERE ARE THE WHERE
ARE THE PEOPLE DOING THIS?
WHERE? WHERE ARE THEY LOCATED?
ARE THEY DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE
STATE OR THEY? THEY CONCENTRATE
IN DIFFERENT PLACES. WE HAVE SIX
REGIONAL OFFICES ACROSS THE
STATE. BUT WE DO GET TO EVERY
COUNTY IN THE STATE. EVERY YEAR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU, SENATOR Dð
RAZO. IF YOU COULD TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. UM UH,
PROMOTING RELINQUISHMENT AT THE
TIME OF CONVICTION OR AT THE
TIME OF RESTRAINING ORDER ISSUES
. I KNOW YOU POINT IDENTIFY SOME
UM BOTH FUNDING AS WELL AS SOME
LEGISLATION. HOW DO YOU, UH,
THO. THOSE ARE, UH, IDENTIFIED
AS RECENT SUCCESSES. SO WHAT IS
THE SUCCESS? THAT THIS IS
PRODUCING UM, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE
I THINK EVERYBODY ON THE I DO ON
THE NATURAL THING WHEN THAT
PERSON IS CONVICTED, THAT'S THE
BEST TIME TO TAKE AWAY THE
FIREARM OR WHEN THERE'S A
RESTRAINING ORDER TO TAKE AWAY
AND WE KNOW THAT THE SOONER WE
TAKE IT AWAY FROM THEM, THE LESS
LIKELY RIGHT FURTHER. UM ISSUES
OR PROBLEMS. SO THESE ARE OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS BECAUSE THESE
REMAIN, UH, PROBLEMS IN THE
STATE BECAUSE EXACTLY THE BEST
TIME TO TAKE A FIREARM FROM
SOMEBODY WHO'S POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS IS NOW UH AND WE HAVE
BEEN PREACHING THAT FOR THE LAST
FEW YEARS IN PARTICULAR, AND WE
HAVE SEEN SUCCESS ON THAT. I
THINK PART OF THE REASON THAT
THE NUMBER OF ADDITIONS ARE
GOING DOWN IN RECENT YEARS IS
BECAUSE THOSE FIREARMS ARE BEING
TAKEN ON THE FRONT END. IT'S
THAT IS ALSO DIFFICULT WORK
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE NOT BRINGING
THEIR FUNDS TO COURT AND SAYING,
OH, HEY, BY THE WAY, HERE'S
HERE'S MY GUN. LET'S LET'S GET
RID OF IT THAT REQUIRES, YOU
KNOW, PROBATION AND WHATNOT. I I
WANTED TO PUT THE RECENT
SUCCESSES ON THERE, BOTH IN
TERMS OF, UM SOME POLICY BILLS
THAT, UH, MANDATED SOME THINGS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND SOME
FUNDING BECAUSE, I HONESTLY
WANTED TO RECOGNIZE THAT THAT
YOU ALL HAVE WE'VE BEEN WE'VE
BEEN MAKING THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND YOU ALL HAVE
BEEN AND I SAY, JUST LISTENING,
BUT PARTICIPATING IN THIS
CONVERSATION WITH US, AND THERE
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSES. THERE, SO I
WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT. BUT
YES, ABSOLUTELY. THOSE ARE WE
STILL HAVE 50% OF THE, UH,
PROHIBITED, UH, PERSONS ON THE
LIST ARE FELONY CONVICTIONS,
WHICH MEANS THEY'RE STANDING IN
COURT TOLD THAT THEY CAN NÓ
LONGER, UH, POSSESS FIREARMS.
AND THEN AND THEN NOTHING
HAPPENS, SO WE STILL HAVE WORK
TO DO. TO CALL THESE, UH,
SUCCESSES FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
IT. IT'D BE BEST TO GIVE US
EXAMPLES OR NUMBERS OR HOW IT'S
ACTUALLY BEING SUCCESSFUL. UH,
BECAUSE YOU KNOW, IN ONE, IT'S
AN ADDITIONAL $40 MILLION IN
ANOTHER ONE. IT'S AN ADDITIONAL
$15 MILLION. I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
JUDGE OK, WE'RE GONNA DO MORE OF
THAT. WHERE IS WHERE IS THE
WHERE'S THE OUTCOME OR THE
RESULTS OF THESE SUCCESSES? SO
AGAIN, THE OUTCOME IS REALLY
FEWER PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING
ADDED ON TO THE TO THE
PROHIBITED PERSONS LIST EVERY
YEAR. SO THIS IS BACK ON, UH,
PAGE TWO. IF YOU LOOK ON AND I'M
SORRY, I COULDN'T FIND THE COLOR
PRINTER THIS MORNING OR A COLOR
PRINTER. UM, BUT THE LIGHTER OF
THE TWO GRAYS, UM IS REMOVALS IN
THE DARKER OF THE TWO GRAYS IS A
ADDITIONS. AND AS YOU CAN SEE,
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS,
THERE'S BEEN DECREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF ADDITIONS YEAR OVER
YEAR FROM 10,762 IN 2020 DOWN TO
JUST UNDER 10 TO JUST OVER NINE
TO ABOUT 8.5 1000 LAST YEAR, SO
THE HARD PART IS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE DATA TO SHOW THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE, UH, THAT THAT THAT
THE FIREARMS SUCCESSFULLY
RETRIEVED AT THE FRONT END.
THAT'S JUST A GAP IN OUR DATA.
UM BUT BUT SEEING THAT RESULT OF
THOSE NUMBERS GOING IS
INDICATIVE OF THAT. AND MAYBE
SUCCESS IS THE WRONG WRONG WAY
TO PUT IT, I, I THINK SAYING,
UH, THE POINT OF THAT IS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CONTRIBUTION
THAT THAT THAT YOU ALL BY WAY OF
THE BUDGET HAVE PUT INTO THIS.
THE HARD PART WITH THIS IS THAT
IT'S GOING TO LOOK DIFFERENT IN
EVERY COUNTY ALPINE COUNTY IS
GONNA LOOK DIFFERENT THAN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO REMOVE THOSE. SO THE
GRANTS UH, AND THE MONEY THAT'S
COMING BY WAY OF A B 28. IS
GOING TO BE HELPFUL SO THAT EACH
COUNTY IS ABLE TO DEVELOP THE
PROCESS THAT WORKS BEST FOR THEM
. SO IT'S STILL IN PROCESS AND
EXACTLY PROBABLY PROBABLY NOT
CORRECT TO CALL IT A SUCCESS AT
THIS POINT MORE OF A LEGISLATIVE
AND BUDGET SUCCESS FROM FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE. E, A Ó. UM ANITA
LEE WITH THE L A Ó TO SENATOR
DE RAZA'S QUESTION. UM YOU HEARD
BOTH OF THESE AS PART OF YOUR
JUDICIAL BRANCH HEARING. BUT IF
IT'S HELPFUL, SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO THE 40 MILLION, THOSE
GRANTS WERE AWARDED TO, UM, EAT,
UH, COUNTIES PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN COURTS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT, UM, AT THE
BEGINNING OF 2020 THREE, AND SO
THEY SHOULD BE COLLECTING
INFORMATION TO KIND OF CAPTURE
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN. UM, JUST AS A
REMINDER, THOUGH, THAT AS PART
OF THIS YEAR'S BUDGET 20 MILLION
OF THAT. 40 MILLION, UM, IS
PROPOSED TO BE REVERTED AS A
BUDGET SOLUTION. AND THEN, UM,
RELATED TO EB 28. WE HAD A
LITTLE BIT OF A DISCUSSION ABOUT
HOW CURRENTLY AS PART OF THE
BUDGET. UM THERE ARE NÓ
PROPOSALS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR EXPENDITURES
OF THOSE DOLLARS IN 2425. THE
PROPOSALS ARE EXPECTED TO COME
IN 2526. AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN
CONSIDER, UM, AS ITS SOLIDIFYING
ITS BUDGET, SO WE JUST WANTED TO
ADD THOSE COMMENTS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. UM I ALSO JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE HAD THEIR
LARGEST CONVENING EVER BASICALLY
ON GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION THIS
PAST DECEMBER, WHICH I WAS A
PART OF, UM AND THEY ARE LOOKING
TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT UH LET'S SAY
PARTNERSHIP SLASH INVESTMENT
SLASH YOU NAME IT IN REGARDS TO
GUN VIOLENCE. PREVENTION UM, YOU
KNOW, I SPECIFICALLY WANTED TO
UNDERSTAND. CAN THE DEPARTMENT
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE GUN
VIOLENCE REDUCTION GRANT
PROGRAM. ARE THERE ANY COUNTIES
PLANNING ON CONTINUING THE WORK
EVEN THOUGH THE GRANT FUNDING IS
ENDING, OR THE CURRENT BUDGET
SITUATION, YOU KNOW BEING WHAT
IT IS, UH, WHAT CAN WE LOOK AT
TO ENSURE THAT YOU KNOW THE
LOCAL COUNTIES AND SO FORTH CAN
MOVE FORWARD WITH THESE PRO
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS. SO, AS
YOU SAID, THE MONEY IS ENDING.
I'M I THINK WE'RE OPTIMISTIC
THAT, UH, THE PLANS THAT THEY
PUT IN PLACE WILL CONTINUE. BUT
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING SPECIFIC
ABOUT WHAT EACH COUNTY IS GOING
TO CONTINUE TO DO, BUT BUT AGAIN
, THAT WAS THE HOPE WAS THAT
THEY DEVELOP PROCESSES THAT
WOULD REMAIN IN PLACE. ALL RIGHT
, AND THEN I ALSO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE NUMBER OF
PROHIBITED PERSONS ON THE LIST
DECREASED, BUT IT'S LESS THAN 2.
YES. OH, NÓ ABS. ABSOLUTELY. ALL
RIGHT. SO UH, I, I JUST WANNA
HIGHLIGHT TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTARY AND OBVIOUSLY WHEN WE
SEE SUCCESSES, UM WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS
YEAR OVER YEAR. UM, VERSUS, YOU
KNOW, 2% RIGHT, SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. WE CAN MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. THANK YOU.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE IS LITIGATION
DEPOSIT FUND LOAN. WE'RE GOING
TO FIRST HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THIS
ISSUE, ANTHONY AND I APOLOGIZE
IF I RUIN YOUR NAME. UH, FRANZO?
YEAH. IT'S PRETTY CLOSE HERE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. IT'S F
LAWYER, FRANS. WHAT FRIENDS
WHERE I WAS CLOSE. I WAS CLOSE.
YOU KNOW, I I'VE HEARD MUCH
WORSE. IT'S OK. THANK YOU. BUT
GOOD MORNING CHAIR WILL HAVE AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMITTEE. MY
NAME IS ANTHONY FRANZA, UH,
REPRESENTING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I'LL BE PRESENTING
ON ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. WHICH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM Dð Ó J HAVE
ALREADY PRIMED A LITTLE BIT. BUT
TO ADDRESS THE PROJECTED BUDGET
SHORTFALL, THE 2425 GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A BUDGETARY LOAN
OF $100 MILLION FROM THE
LITIGATION DEPOSITS FUND OR THE
L Dð F TO THE GENERAL FUND IN
2425. FROM IDLE RESOURCES THAT
ARE NOT REQUIRED FOR CURRENTLY
PROJECTED OPERATIONAL OR
PROGRAMMATIC PURPOSES. AND AGAIN
. THIS IS AN ADDITION TO THE
$400 OR $400 MILLION BUDGETARY
LOAN FROM THE L Dð F TO THE
GENERAL FUND THAT WAS INCLUDED
IN THE 2020 THREE BUDGET ACT FOR
A TOTAL LOAN AMOUNT OF $500
MILLION. TO CLARIFY Dð Ó J, THE
ADMINISTRATION DO NOT INTEND FOR
THESE LOANS TO EITHER NEGATIVELY
IMPACT EITHER THE L Dð F OR THE
VARIOUS SPECIAL FUNDS RECEIVING
RESOURCES FROM THE L Dð F OR THE
SIGNAL ANY TYPE OF ONGOING
REDUCTIONS. THESE LOANS ARE ONLY
INTENDED AS TOOLS TO HELP CLOSE
THE BUDGET SHORTFALL. AND UNLESS
SOMETHING RADICAL CHANGES IN THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS, Dð Ó J, THE
ADMINISTRATION AGREED THAT THEY
PROPOSED $100 MILLION $100
MILLION LOAN. EXCUSE ME IS
VIABLE. AND FOR THAT PROPOSED
LOAN, WE MADE THE DECISION TO
USE THE L Dð F AS THE SOURCE FOR
THE LOAN, GIVEN THE BEST
AVAILABLE INFORMATION DURING THE
BUDGET DEVELOPMENT PROCESS,
HOWEVER, NOW THE Dð Ó J IS
TRANSFERRED RESOURCES OUT OF THE
L Dð F PURSUANT TO CHAPTER 45
STATUTES OF 2023, WHICH IS A B
127 THE STATE GOVERNMENT TRAILER
BILL FROM LAST YEAR. UH, WHERE
WE'RE RE EVALUATING OUR PROPOSAL
AND ASSESSING WHICH OF THESE
SPECIAL FUNDS THAT RECEIVE
RESOURCES FROM THE L Dð F WOULD
BE MORE APPROPRIATE SOURCES FOR
THE LOAN. AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION WE WILL PROPOSE IS THE
L Ó RECOMMENDS AN UPDATE THIS
PROPOSED LOAN THAT USES THE
VARIOUS SPECIAL FUNDS AS SOURCE
FOR THE LOAN INSTEAD OF THE L Dð
F ITSELF, AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
COMMENTS AND AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU, L A Ó.
ANITA LEE WITH THE L A Ó. UM,
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
INDICATED, UM, AN OPENNESS TO
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS, BUT FOR THE
RECORD, WE WILL PRESENT THEM. UM
UH IN FULL AND SO WE DO HAVE
THREE RECOMMENDATIONS ON THIS
ISSUE. WE DO RECOMMEND REJECTING
THE PROPOSED LOAN FROM THE L Dð
F BECAUSE WE THINK THERE ARE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT ITS ABILITY
TO SUPPORT IT. UM AS HIGHLIGHTED
. THERE WAS A $400 MILLION LOAN
THAT WAS MADE LAST YEAR FROM THE
L Dð F TO THE GENERAL FUND AND A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONIES
WERE TRANSFERRED FROM THE L Dð
F. TWO STATE SPECIAL FUNDS, UM,
SUBJECT TO LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
, AND THAT'S REALLY SOMETHING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WAS FOCUSED
ON. SO IN COMBINATION THESE
ACTIONS LEFT ABOUT 100 AND 57
MILLION IN THE FUND BALANCE AS
OF THE END OF DECEMBER OF 2023.
WELL, THAT SOUNDS LIKE A LOT.
MOST OF THOSE MONIES ARE EITHER
TIED TO CASES THAT ARE
UNRESOLVED OR THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE USED FOR VERY NARROW
PURPOSES, SO WE DON'T THINK THAT
THERE ARE A GOOD SOURCE. THE
FIRST CHOICE YOU KNOW, TO BORROW
FROM. INSTEAD WE DO THINK THAT
ONE OR MORE OF THE FOUR Dð Ó J
SPECIAL FUNDS THAT RECEIVED
NEARLY 485 MILLION IN TRANSFERS
FROM THE L Dð F WOULD BE A
BETTER SOURCE TO BORROW FROM AND
SO BECAUSE OF THAT OUR SECOND
RECOMMENDATION IS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO DIRECT Dð Ó J TO
REPORT UM, BY ME REVISION A LIST
OF CASES WHOSE LITIGATION
PROCEEDS COULD BE USED TO
SUPPORT AN ADDITIONAL $100
MILLION IN LOANS ALONG WITH THE
SPECIAL FUNDS FROM WHICH THEY
WOULD BE COMING. SO THAT ALLOWS
Dð Ó J TO THINK ABOUT ITS
CURRENT AND FUTURE WORKLOAD, AS
WELL AS HOW MUCH COULD BE
BORROWED WITHOUT IMPACTING THEIR
OPERATIONS. THIS TYPE OF LIST
WOULD ALSO BE HELPFUL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN MONITORING LOAN
REPAYMENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN THE MONEY COMES BACK IN,
WE'RE STICKING WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THE UNDERLYING COURT
JUDGMENTS OR THE SETTLEMENTS
RELATED TO THEM, AND SO THEN OUR
FINAL OUR THIRD AND FINAL
RECOMMENDATION IS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE THAT LIST
PROVIDED IN MAY REVISION, MAKE
ANY CHANGES THAT ARE AND THEN
MODIFY THE BUDGET TO REFLECT
LOANS FROM THE VARIOUS SPECIAL
FUNDS INCLUDED ON THE FINAL
LIST. IN ADDITION TO ANY LOAN
THAT'S MADE WE DO RECOMMEND
REPORTING LANGUAGE. FOR CERTAIN
INFORMATION, SUCH AS IF THERE'S
ANY RESTRICTIONS ON THE MONEY,
THIS REPORTING LANGUAGE WOULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE REPORTING
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRED FOR THE
PRIOR $400 MILLION LOAN, AND
THIS TYPE OF INFORMATION WOULD
HELP ENSURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS THE INFORMATION TO MONITOR
AND TRACK THE INFORMATION AND
ENSURE THE MONEY IS USED
ACCOUNTABLY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, UH, COMMENTS FROM Dð Ó J.
NÓ. THANK YOU, UH, MEMBERS OF
THE PANEL. SENATOR NEWMAN, UM TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IT. I
DON'T SEE ANY INDICATION AS TO
AN EXPECTED DATE OR SCHEDULE FOR
REPAYMENT OF THE LOANS. FOR THE
PROPOSED $100 BILLION LOAN. WE
DIDN'T INCLUDE A LOAN REPAYMENT
DATE BECAUSE OF AGAIN THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE TRAILER
BILL AND THE PROPOSAL. UM IT IT
AGAIN DURING THE BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS. WE WEREN'T
SURE EXACTLY WHICH FUNDS WOULD
BE TRANSFERRED OUT SO JUST BY
NATURE OF HAVING TO MAKE
DECISIONS FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, WE CHOSE TO USE THE L Dð
F, BUT, UM THAT LOAN REPAYMENT
DATE FOR THE L Dð F WOULD NÓ
LONGER HAVE BEEN ACCURATE
BECAUSE WE NEEDED TO UPDATE. UH,
THE FUND SOURCE FOR MAY REVISION
. UM, IN GENERAL, I THINK MOST
GENERAL FUND REPAYMENTS TO
SPECIAL FUNDS HAPPEN IN BUDGET
YEAR THREE OR FOUR. BUT AGAIN
THAT'S ALSO MADE ON A CASE BY
CASE BASIS, DEPENDING ON THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS OF THAT SPECIAL
FUND. SO THE LOAN REPAYMENT, UH,
WILL BE PART OF THE MAYOR VISION
WITH THE UPDATED. APPRECIATE
THAT, SO I GUESS THAT, UM SPEAKS
TO THE LAO'S RECOMMENDATION FOR
KIND OF ENHANCED TRACKING
REPORTING AGAINST THOSE FUNDS.
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER.
APPRECIATE THE INPUT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DE RASA. THANK YOU. UM
THIS IS, UH, DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, GIVEN THAT THE
LITIGATION DEPOSIT FUND REVENUES
ARE PRIMARILY TRANSFERRED TO Dð
Ó J SPECIAL FUNDS, FOR EXAMPLE,
UM THE UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW
FUND. WE USE THAT TO FUND
TENANTS RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT LAST
YEAR. WHAT IS THE IMPACT OF THIS
PROPOSED LOAN ON THE CURRENT
WORK THAT THE Dð Ó J IS DOING?
THAT'S SURE. UM WE ARE IN
AGREEMENT THAT THE PROPOSED LOAN
WOULD NEED TO BE TAKEN FROM THE
SPECIAL FUNDS. THE UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAW FUND COULD
POTENTIALLY BE ONE OF THOSE
FUNDS, WHICH THE LOAN COULD
POSSIBLY BE TAKEN FROM, UM,
BASED ON CURRENT SUSTAINABILITY
ESTIMATES, IT'S ANTICIPATED THAT
THE ADDITIONAL LOAN WOULD BE
FEASIBLE, UM, AND FOR Dð Ó J TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE EXISTING
OPERATIONS. UM, IT WOULD BE
FEASIBLE FOR THE IMMEDIATE
FUTURE AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH, UH, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ON THE PROPOSED LOAN REPAYMENT
SCHEDULE, UM, TO ENSURE THAT
OPERATIONS ARE NOT IMPACTED. OK?
THAT MEANS WE'RE CON CONTINUE
WITH OUR TENANTS. RIGHTS
ENFORCEMENT, SENATOR TORAZO JUST
TO CHRIS RYAN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. WE
FACTORED THAT INTO OUR
CALCULATION WHEN WE'RE
DETERMINING HOW MUCH FUNDING WE
HAVE, AND THE PERIOD OF TIME
THAT IT'S GONNA BE AVAILABLE FOR
AND WE COMMUNICATE THAT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND ALONG
THESE LINES AND WHAT OUR L A Ó
SAID, UM, WE TOOK LAST YEAR WE
TOOK ACTION TO INCREASE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT IN TWO
WAYS. UM AND SO I WANNA SEE IF
THAT KIND OF SPECIFICITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IS IN YOUR
PROPOSAL THIS TIME, SO THE FIRST
ONE WAS, WE REQUIRED THAT, UM
MOST LITIGATION PROCEEDS BE
TRANSFERRED TO A STATE SPECIAL
FUNDING. UH, WITHIN THREE MONTHS
AFTER THE CASE WAS RESOLVED TO
ENSURE THESE FUNDS ARE
CONSIDERED, UM, IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS. UM THE SECOND ONE WAS.
WE PLACED ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS ON WHAT MONEY IS
ALLOWED TO BE TRANSFERRED. I
KNOW WE SORT OF BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS ALREADY. BUT IF YOU
COULD ANSWER, THAT'D BE GREAT.
YEAH SO Dð Ó J HAS BEEN WORKING
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS TO
BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THAT
REQUIREMENT TO TRANSFER ALL OF
THE FUNDS. AND AS OF DECEMBER,
UH WE HAD TRANSFERRED THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE FUNDS AND WE
CONTINUE TO TRANSFER THE FUNDS,
UM, PURSUANT TO THE REQUIRED
TIME FRAMES AND THE SPECIFIC
CRITERIA LAID OUT IN STATUTE,
UM, FOR THOSE TRANSFERS TO
OCCUR. SO. A SO AND
ACCOUNTABILITY YES, IT'S UH WE
ARE REPORTING QUARTERLY ON THE
TRANSFERS THAT WERE MADE. SO
THERE'S SPECIFIC REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. UM ON LAID OUT IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ACT, AND WE
ARE COMPLYING WITH THOSE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. THANK
YOU, SENATOR DE RAZO. UM ALL
RIGHT. NÓ FURTHER QUESTIONS. WE
CAN MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX.
WE APPRECIATE Dð Ó J S¼, UH,
TESTIMONY. UM ITEM NUMBER SIX.
WE'RE GOING TO START OFF WITH
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
WE'RE GOING TO FIRST HEAR FROM
NANCY WARD. UM YOU WILL HAVE
FIVE MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR,
SENATORS. I'M NANCY WARD,
DIRECTOR OF CALL Ó E. AND WITH
ME TODAY IS ERIC SWANSON, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OUR FINANCE AND
ADMIN, UH, DIRECTORATE. THE
GOVERNORS BUDGET PROPOSES $3
BILLION FOR CALLOW E 530 POINT
THREE IN GENERAL FUND IN 1909
POSITIONS. I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THIS COMMITTEE. CONTINUED
SUPPORT IN PROVIDING RESOURCES
TO ENSURE WE FULFILL OUR ROLE AS
SERVING AS A STATE'S LEADERSHIP
HUB DURING ALL MAJOR EMERGENCIES
AND DISASTERS WHEN INCLUDING ALL
FUNDING SOURCES, THE BIGGEST
COMPONENT OF OUR BUDGET IS IN
LOCAL ASSISTANCE. KOW SERVES AS
A STATE ADMINISTRATING AGENT FOR
FEDERAL HOMELAND SECURITY,
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND VICTIM
SERVICES GRANTS AND IS THE
PRIMARY LIAISON WITH THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY AS FEDERAL EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT. AGENCY IN 2024 25.
THE BUDGET ESTIMATES WE WILL
ALLOCATE 1.9 BILLION TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES, TRIBES AND
NONPROFIT AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
FRONT LINE SUPPORT AND PREPARING
AND RESPONDING TO EMERGENCIES,
PREVENTING CYBER CRIMES,
PROVIDING DIRECT SERVICES TO
VICTIMS AND MANY OTHER ESSENTIAL
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS. A
MAJORITY OF OUR GENERAL FUND IS
DEDICATED TO EMERGENCY SERVICES,
WHICH I'LL GET INTO MORE DETAIL
IN JUST A SECOND. BUT HOWEVER,
THE COMMITTEE IS ALSO ASKED ME
TO DISCUSS A REQUIREMENT OR
ARTICULATED IN THE LAST FEW
BUDGET CYCLES FOR CALLOW TO
ENSURE A REPORT THAT OUTLINES
OUR OPERATIONAL VISIONS OR
RESPONSE GAP ANALYSIS. THE
INTENT OF THE REPORT IS TO
IDENTIFY THE TYPES OF RISK Kò Ó
E CONSIDERS DURING PLANNING AND
PREPAREDNESS EFFORTS, THE
FRAMEWORK UTILIZED TO IDENTIFY
THE APPROPRIATE RESOURCE
CAPABILITIES, EXISTING PROGRAMS
THAT SUPPORT THE FRAMEWORK GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES FOR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. HOW RECENTLY APPROVED
RESOURCES SUPPORT THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
AND THE GAPS THAT MAY EXIST IN
THE CURRENT RESOURCES. WE HAVE
UTILIZED INTERNAL INTERVIEWS AND
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT. PUT TO
DEVELOP THE REPORT. THE REPORT
IS IN THE FINAL APPROVAL PROCESS
AND SHOULD BE DISSEMINATED VERY
SHORTLY. I WAS ALSO ASKED TO
TOUCH ON THE REDUCTIONS INCLUDED
IN OUR PROPOSED BUDGET. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IDENTIFIES
FISCAL SOLUTIONS WHERE THE
FUNDING HAD NOT YET BEEN AWARDED
TO SPECIFIC. GROUPS OR AGENCIES.
THE MAJORITY OF OUR PROPOSED
SOLUTIONS INVOLVE NEW OR PILOT
PROGRAMS. IT'S NEVER EASY TO
PROPOSE BUDGET SOLUTIONS, BUT
OUR GOAL WAS TO PRESERVE OUR
EXISTING LOCAL AND STATE
CAPACITY TO RESPOND TO DISASTERS
AND EMERGENCIES AND HONOR ANY
EXISTING COMMITMENTS TO LOCAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS. KOS IS A
WORLD CLASS LEADER IN EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AND HOMELAND SECURITY
. OUR MISSION IS TO PROTECT
LIVES AND PROPERTY, BUILD
CAPACITIES AND SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR A RES.
CALIFORNIA. SIMPLY PUT Kò Ó E
S¼ S¼ ROLE AS THAT OF CO
ORDINATION. WE ARE CHARGED WITH
ANTICIPATING PLANNING AND
PREPARING TO COORDINATE CRITICAL
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES TO PROTECT LIVES AND
PROPERTY AND TO SUPPORT THEIR
RECOVERY FROM DISASTERS. OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS, THE
STATE HAS EXPERIENCED AN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS.
SEVERE DROUGHT, CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES, POWER GRID AND OUTAGE
CHALLENGES. EARTHQUAKES A
GENERATIONAL PANDEMIC AND
INTENSIVE STORMS WITH SEVERE
FLOODING. 15 OF THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY HAVE HAPPENED SINCE 2015
7 OF WHICH IN JUST THE LAST FOUR
YEARS, CALIFORNIA HAS MOVED INTO
A NEW CHAPTER OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AND DISASTER RESPONSE
AND RECOVERY. EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS ARE MUCH MORE FREQUENT
, MORE SEVERE, MORE CHALLENGING
AND COMPLICATED AND INVOLVING
MULTIPLE COUNTIES AND REGIONS OF
THE STATE SIMULTANEOUSLY. FOR
THE RECENT JANUARY FEBRUARY
STORM EVENTS, GOVERNOR NEWSOM
REQUESTED AND RECEIVED A FEDERAL
MAJOR DISASTER DECLARATION,
WHICH PROVIDED INDIVIDUAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS FOR SAN
DIEGO COUNTY FOLLOWING THE
JANUARY STORM. IN REGARD TO THE
MOST RECENT FEBRUARY STORM
SYSTEM. WE ARE FINALIZING WITH
THE FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
ARE DAMAGE ASSESSMENTS, AND WE
HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH FA TO
CONDUCT DAMAGE ASSESSMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE HARDEST HIT
COUNTIES AND TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT WE
MEET THE FEDERAL THRESHOLD. LIKE
YOU. I'VE WITNESSED TOO MANY
TIMES THE DEVASTATION OF A
COMMUNITY HIT BY CATASTROPHIC
DISASTER. THE RECOVERY PROCESS
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AS LONG AND
CHALLENGING IN PARTICULARLY
DEVASTATE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES OF OUR
STATE. WE HAVE TAKEN STEPS TO
BETTER SUPPORT THESE COMMUNITIES
. WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A PRIORITY
POPULATIONS TASK FORCE CHARGED
WITH IDENTIFYING WAYS TO PROTECT
AND PREPARE CALIFORNIANS WHO
THESE STORMS THREATENED. THE
MOST MATERIALS ARE DELIBERATELY
PREPARED TO BE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY, UH, INVITING,
ACCESSIBLE, RESPECTFUL AND
USEFUL LANGUAGE LIKEWISE,
INTENTIONALLY DESIGNED TO BE
PEOPLE CENTERED, AND PEOPLE
POWERED WITH LOCAL TIMES. SORRY.
THAT'S ALL RIGHT. YEAH. UM, YOU
KNOW, I APPRECIATE IT, UH, A Ó.
NOTHING PERMANENT FINANCE
NOTHING. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT. I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS MYSELF. UM
SPECIFICALLY, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
A HIGH VACANCY RATE, UM,
OBVIOUSLY THROUGH THROUGHOUT
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS, BUT, UM,
YOU KNOW WHAT IS, UH, Ó E S¼
TRYING TO DO PARTICULARLY TO
FILL THESE UH, VACANCIES. IT'S
BEEN DIFFICULT. THERE'S NÓ
QUESTION ABOUT IT. TO BE QUITE
HONEST, WE'RE LOOKING AT RESUMES
THAT FIVE YEARS AGO. WE PROBABLY
WOULDN'T EVEN UH UH, HAVE JOINED
US FOR AN INTERVIEW. QUITE
FRANKLY, SO WE'RE GOING OUT TO
UNIVERSITIES. WE'RE USING
LINKEDIN. WE'RE USING, UH, ALL
OF OUR TOOLS. UM A WOUNDED
WARRIOR. UM UH, ALL OF OUR TOOLS
THAT WE CAN OUR OTHER, UH LOCAL
AGENCIES, EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCIES. THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AGENCY AS WELL TO GET
THE WIDEST NET WE POSSIBLY CAN.
BUT IT IS VERY, VERY TOUGH,
UNDERSTOOD, AND HOW IS Kò Ó E
GOING LIKE? WHAT IS Kò Ó E S¼
GOING TO DO TO CONTRIBUTE TO
SOLVING THE BUDGET DEFICIT. I'LL
ASK ERIC WHEN I TAKE THAT, UM
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ASSUMES
SEVERAL PROPOSALS THERE IN YOUR
AGENDA. UM THE WAY THAT I WOULD
CHARACTERIZE THEM ARE THEIR, UH
UM SORT OF NEW OR PILOT GRANT
PROGRAMS, INCLUDING THE FLEXIBLE
SURVIVORS PROGRAM, WHICH WE'RE
GONNA HAVE IN ANOTHER AGENDA
ITEM. UM WE ALSO HAD A
MULTIFAMILY UH UH UH,
EARTHQUAKE. GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WAS SCHEDULED TO START THAT WAS
BRAND NEW AND WE'VE, UH AND THAT
IS NOT PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. WE HAVE A COUPLE OF,
UM, HOME HARDENING, OR, UH,
COMMUNITY HARDENING PROGRAMS
WHERE WE HADN'T ALLOCATED THE
FUNDS TO, UH, COUNTIES OR LOCALS
OR IN OR, UH, HOMES YET, SO AND
WE'RE PROPOSING TO, UH, TO NOT
CONTINUE WITH THOSE AT THIS
POINT. THANK YOU. AND YOU KNOW
SLIGHTLY A LITTLE OFF TOPIC, BUT
Kò Ó E WAS RECENTLY IN THE NEWS
, UM, RELATED TO, UH, SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIM. UH, HOW IS
CALLOW ES, ENSURING THAT IT'S A
SAFE PLACE FOR WOMEN TO WORK FOR
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS AND WHAT
PROPORTION OF Kò Ó E STAFF ARE
WOMEN. AND WHAT ARE WE TAKING A
STEPS TO DIVERSIFY THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE FORCE? WE'RE TAKING ALL
STEPS TO TRY AND DIVERSIFY. FOR
SURE. I MEAN, IT IS A AN
INDUSTRY IF YOU WILL, OVER MY 40
YEARS IN EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT,
WHERE IT WAS MALE CENTRIC.
THERE'S JUST NÓ QUESTION ABOUT
THAT. SO WE ARE TRYING VERY,
VERY HARD TO DIVERSIFY IN MANY,
MANY WAYS, OUR WORKFORCE AND TO
THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT. I WILL
TELL YOU TRAINING, TRAINING AND
TRAINING. UM WE HAVE STARTED AN
EXTENSIVE TRAINING PROCESS
FORWARD FOR NOT ONLY OUR STAFF,
BUT ALSO FOCUSING ON OUR
LEADERSHIP AS WELL. OK, PERFECT.
THANK YOU. UM I. I DO WANNA JUST
PRIORITIZE THIS. I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I CARE A LOT
ABOUT BESIDES THE NATURAL
DISASTERS THAT WE'RE SEEING IN
THE FIRES AND SO FORTH. UM BUT
ALSO EVEN RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
YOU GUYS MAY HAVE AS TO WHAT
CAUSES THESE FIRES. WHAT? WHAT
DO YOU SEE AS, UM YOU KNOW,
RECOMMENDATIONS, RIGHT? UM SO WE
ALSO KNOW THAT A LOT OF FIRES
ARE BECAUSE OF THE PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE AND
THE LACK OF INVESTMENT FROM SOME
ORGANIZATIONS IN A BETTER
INFRASTRUCTURE. GIVEN CLIMATE
CHANGE, AND SO MUCH MORE RIGHT
FOR THE CHANGE IS THE WORD UM
AND IT BUT IT'S MORE THAN THAT.
OBVIOUSLY RAY, YOU KNOW, THERE
ARE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE NOT,
UM PUTTING THE PROPER LINES IN
THE GROUND AND MAKING SURE THAT
YOU KNOW WE CAN HAVE SOME
SECURITY AND SAFETY AND SO FORTH
THAT WE CONTROL, RIGHT. UM WITH
THAT SAID ONE OF THE OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS THAT THAT I
REALLY WANT TO UNDERSTAND IS,
UM, CYBER SECURITY. RIGHT UH,
CYBER SECURITY FALLS UNDER YOU
GUYS. CORRECT OK, SO IN MY AREA,
AND I'M SURE IN PLENTY OF OTHER
CITIES, UM MANY CITIES AS WELL
AS JUST JURISDICTIONS, SCHOOL
BOARDS, COLLEGES SO FORTH. UM
THEY HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH
CYBER SECURITY ATTACKS LEFT AND
RIGHT, UM, ABSORBING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDS FROM
THEM BECAUSE THEY HAVE NÓ WAY TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES AS WELL AS
PREVENT IT AND SO FORTH, UM, AND
THE COST OF INVESTMENT FOR THESE
JURISDICTIONS IS QUITE
SIGNIFICANT FOR A SMALL CITY
TOWN. THINGS LIKE THAT, UM, AND
THE RANSOM THAT THAT SOME OF
THESE, UH PERPETRATORS ARE
ASKING FOR IS SOMETIMES VERY
SMALL, SOMETIMES A LOT LARGER
AND THE RECOMMENDATION TO MANY
OF THESE FOLKS HAVE BEEN TO GIVE
THE MONEY UP. RIGHT WHICH I
THINK IS A VERY POOR
RECOMMENDATION, RIGHT? AND WHAT
IS CALLOW DOING PROACTIVELY TO
HELP JURISDICTIONS THAT TO YOUR
POINT, AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT
ACROSS THE BOARD IN MULTIPLE
PRESENTATIONS, AS WE HAVE A LACK
OF QUALIFIED TALENT. WE HAVE A
LACK OF, UM, UH, ABILITY TO FILL
POSITIONS IN NEED, INCLUDING
CYBER SECURITY, WHICH IS, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE COMPETING WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR OF THE BEST
TALENT. AND UM, EVEN IN THE
PREVIOUS CONVERSATIONS, WE'VE
SEEN THAT AN INVESTMENT IN
SUBSCRIPTION MODELS AND
TECHNOLOGY AND SO FORTH CONTINUE
TO GROW. IT'S NOT A STATIC COST
OF, YOU KNOW, HOWEVER MANY
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS UM AND EVEN
FOR SMALL, UH, JURISDICTIONS.
IT'S PUSHING IN THE MILLIONS,
RIGHT? WHAT ARE YOU GUYS DOING
PROACTIVELY TO PROVIDE THE TOOLS
AND RESOURCES TO THESE
JURISDICTIONS. WELL, FIRST OF
ALL, I WOULD SAY, OUR CYBER THE
UNIT IN DIVISION OF HOMELAND
SECURITY IS PRETTY ROBUST IN
GETTING MORE ROBUST EACH DAY
BECAUSE WE ARE DOING HIRING
THERE. IT IS DIFFICULT, I. I
AGREE WITH YOU. UM BUT THEY TAKE
ALL CALLS FROM ANY JURISDICTION
SCHOOLS, UH, CITY GOVERNMENTS,
AND THEY WILL HELP OUR RESOURCES
WILL HELP THEM IDENTIFY THE, UM
UH, THREAT ACTOR WILL HELP THEM.
UM UM I WOULD SAY. SOLIDIFY
THEIR AND FORTIFY THEIR SYSTEMS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WILL
SAY, THOUGH, IN TERMS OF
RANSOMWARE IS A LOT OF THESE
ENTITIES NOW ARE GETTING THEIR
OWN CYBERSECURITY INSURANCE. AND
WHEN THEY DO, THE INSURANCE
REQUIRES THEM THAT THEY DON'T
REALLY SPEAK ABOUT THE ATTACK.
AND SO IT'S VERY DIFFICULT WHEN
WE HEAR ABOUT AN ATTACK AND
OFFER UP OUR RESOURCES TO ANY OF
THESE AGENCIES THAT THEY CAN'T
REALLY SPEAK TO US, UH, ABOUT
SOME OF THE INTRICACIES OF HOW
THE ACTOR GOT INTO THEIR SYSTEM.
WHAT WAS DONE, AND SO THEY ON
THEIR OWN, WILL DECIDE TO GO
AHEAD AND PAY THE RANSOMWARE,
WHICH WE AGREE IS NOT THE BEST
AVENUE TO TAKE IN IN THESE, BUT
WE ARE, UM DOING, UH, GRANT
PROGRAMS FOR CYBER SECURITY AND
WE ARE ALSO IN THE MIDST OF
DEVELOPING SERVICES WITH OUR
CYBERSECURITY OFFICE, WHICH IS A
COMBINATION OF NOT ONLY, UH,
CALLOW E S¼, BUT THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT èC Dð Tð. UH AND THE
èC HÌ P AND WE ARE WORKING TO
OPEN UP THAT SERVICE SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN EITHER CHOOSE TO
UTILIZE OUR SERVICE, OR WE CAN
PAY THEM TO GET THOSE SERVICES
ON THE OUTSIDE. THERE ARE GRANTS
. SO YOU GUYS STEP IN WHEN YOU
GUYS HEAR ABOUT IT IN THE NEWS,
CORRECT? THEY THEY THEY
TYPICALLY JUST CONTACT US, NÓ
THEY THEY THERE IS A SYSTEM IN
PLACE. NOT ONLY THAT, BUT WE
SEND OUT TO THE ALL OF THESE
JURISDICTIONS. UM TIPS, UH,
THINGS TO LOOK FOR HOW TO UM,
FORTIFY THEIR SYSTEMS AND THEN
THEY CAN CALL US ANY TIME TO ASK
FOR OUR SERVICES WHEN THEY GET
HACKED. AND THE REASON WHY I SAY
THIS IS I'VE HOSTED, OBVIOUSLY,
UM A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT EVENTS
AND HAVE UTILIZE THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE. BUT MANY OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS THESE CITIES,
THESE SCHOOLS, THESE
JURISDICTIONS, UM THEY GENERALLY
DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE, UH,
SHARING THEIR YOU KNOW THEIR
THEIR PROBLEM AREAS BECAUSE IT'S
WEAKNESSES. IT'S POTENTIAL
SECURITY THREATS AND, LIKE YOU
KNOW, HOLES IN THEIR SYSTEM, IF
YOU WILL, UM, ALSO RECRUITING
PEOPLE FOR THEIR DEPARTMENT OF
IT AND SO FORTH, ESPECIALLY IN
MY DISTRICT, WHICH IS SILICON
VALLEY. UM THERE'S NÓ WAY THAT
WE, A GOVERNMENT AGENCY CAN PAY
THEM ENOUGH COMPARED TO ANY OF
THE TECH, YOU KNOW, UM SO, UM,
II, I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A LITTLE
BIT MORE ROBUST ACTION, AND IT'S
NOT JUST THESE MUNICIPALITIES
AND JURISDICTIONS THAT, UM, ARE
HAVING DIFFICULTY AND OFTENTIMES
I WILL SAY THIS THEY DON'T EVEN
KNOW THAT THERE ARE RESOURCES
OUT FOR THEM. UM SO JUST EVEN
SEEING A MORE PROACTIVE APPROACH
. UM, MY OFFICE IS MORE THAN
HAPPY TO WORK WITH, UH, YOUR
TEAM AND YOUR DEPARTMENT AS AS
WELL, UM, BUT IT'S ALSO EVEN
TIPS AND TRICKS FOR SMALLER
BUSINESSES AS WE SEE BRICK AND
MORTAR ORGANIZATIONS KIND OF
FALL. UM, AND OBVIOUSLY WE SEE
RETAIL THEFT AND SO FORTH. UH,
WE'RE SEEING A LOT MORE, UH,
ATTACKS ON SOME OF THESE SMALLER
BUSINESSES THAT ARE MOVING INTO
THE ONLINE SPACE, AND THEY HAVE
NÓ RESOURCES, MANY OF THEM
IMMIGRANTS TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
HOW TO EVEN GET INTO THE ONLINE
MARKET SPACE SO AS MUCH AS WE
CAN THINKING THAT, YOU KNOW, I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A BIGGER
INVESTMENT IN THIS AREA. UH, AND
SOME GROWTH AND SOME A VERY
ROBUST MARKETING PLAN AND, UM,
HAND HOLDING. I HATE TO SAY IT
LIKE THAT, BUT, UH, NÓ, BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT. I THINK WE CAN
CERTAINLY MAKE A WIDER NET OF
OUR, UH, DEVELOPED, UH,
INFORMATION THAT WE SEND OUT ON
THE REGULAR TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND AS FAR AS THE
SCHOOLS OR AS RECENT LEGISLATION
THAT PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR, UH, OUR
CYBERSECURITY TEAM TO BE ABLE TO
AND REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO LET US
KNOW WHEN THEY HAVE, UH, HAD AN
ATTACK AND THE REASON FOR THAT
IS BECAUSE IS IDENTITY THEFT
PEOPLE'S SOCIAL SECURITY. IT'S
LIKE A BUNCH OF STUDENTS, SOCIAL
SECURITY, SO THERE'S THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF LIKE A DOMINO
EFFECT OF ONE ATTACK, SO I
APPRECIATE IT. UM I WILL MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN FLEXIBLE
ASSISTANCE FOR SURVIVORS OF
CRIME DELAY. WE'RE GOING TO
FIRST HEAR FROM I'M GOING TO
RUIN THIS NAME. UH, GINA. WHO?
HARRINGTON THAT'S IT. THAT'S
GOOD. GOOD OK, THANK YOU, THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF GRANTS
MANAGEMENT AT CAL Ó E. THANK
YOU. SO, ACTUALLY, I'M GOING TO
START OFF WITH AN INTRO. I'M
ERIC SWANSON AGAIN. DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION FOR Kò. Ó E S¼.
THE NEXT ISSUE ON YOUR AGENDA IS
ASSOCIATED WITH A PROPOSED DELAY
OF 47.5 MILLION GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATED IN THE 2 2022
BUDGET ACT TO ESTABLISH AN
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO IMPROVE
THE SAFETY, HEALING AND
FINANCIAL STABILITY FOR
SURVIVORS AND THE LOVED ONES OF
THOSE VIOLENTLY INJURED OR
KILLED. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ASSUMES 47.5 MILLION FOR THIS
PROGRAM, STARTING IN 2025 26
RATHER THAN, UH, THIS COMING
FISCAL YEAR. WE'VE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ESTABLISHED TO THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATION TO CREATE
PARAMETERS OF THE GRANT PROGRAM,
AND, UH, WE WILL BE READY TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM AS OF JULY
1ST 2025 AS YOU SAID MY
COLLEAGUE, MS BIERI, HERRINGTON
AND I ARE AVAILABLE FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. NOTHING
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NOTHING
UH, MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
SENATOR Dð RAZO, UM JUST TO
CURIOSITY, WHY NOT DELAY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PORTION I THINK
WE'VE ALREADY WE ALREADY STARTED
WORKING ON IT. WE UH UM WE THIS
FALL? WE UH UH, GOT TOGETHER
WITH THERE WERE, UH,
APPOINTMENTS FROM BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
THIS ADVISORY COMMITTEE AS IT
WAS ESTABLISHED IN THE
LEGISLATION, SO WE, UH, WORKED
WITH THEM TO CREATE, UH, THE
PARAMETERS OF THE RFP. THERE'S
STILL MORE WORK TO DO WE NEED TO
DO, UH UH, MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE,
UH, GETTING THIS OUT AND UM AND
PUBLICIZING IT AND GET READY FOR
THE ACTUAL RELEASE OF THE RFP
WHEN IT COMES, BUT UM, THERE'S
STILL MORE WORK, AND I SHOULD
ALSO SAY THAT THAT
ADMINISTRATION FUNDING IS NOT
JUST FOR THIS YEAR OR NEXT YEAR.
IT'S FOR THE LIFE OF THE ENTIRE
GRANT PROCESS. UH, FOUR YEARS
WAS THE LEGISLATION. DO YOU HAVE
ANY? OK THANK YOU, UH, SIGN NÓ
FURTHER QUESTIONS. YOU KNOW, I
HAVE A COUPLE MYSELF. UH, WHY
ISN'T ASSOCIATED ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNDING ALSO BEING DELAYED? YEAH
WE SORT OF. WE TALKED ABOUT THAT
A LITTLE BIT THE, UM IT'S FOR
THE LIFE OF THE GRANT PROGRAM
OVER FOUR YEARS, AND WE ALREADY
STARTED THE, UM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES
ASSOCIATED WITH CREATING THE
PARAMETERS OF THE GRANT WORKING
WITH THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE. ALL
RIGHT, IS THIS A PURELY FISCAL
DECISION OR ARE THERE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE PROGRAM? NÓ.
ACTUALLY I THINK WE'RE FANS JUST
AS MUCH AS YOU ARE OF THE
PROGRAM. THIS SITS IN A SPACE
THAT I THINK IS NOT SERVED. IT
PROVIDES MORE FLEXIBLE
ASSISTANCE THAN UM OTHER
PROGRAMS. I THINK, UM THE
ADMINISTRATION AGREES THAT THERE
IS A NEED FOR THIS. THEY WOULD
JUST DELAYING IT. ONE YEAR FOR
FISCAL REASONS. ALL RIGHT,
PERFECT. THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
PUBLIC SAFETY RADIO
MODERNIZATION TO SUPPORT EQUAL
ACCESS TO 911 SERVICES. WE ARE
GOING TO FIRST HEAR FROM BUDGET.
CARRIER ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS AT
CAL OES. YES THE FINAL SHOW ON
YOUR AGENDA IS REQUEST FOR 6.4
MILLION IN STATE EMERGENCY
TELEPHONE NUMBER ACCOUNT OR SET
A FUND AUTHORITY FOR 13 EXISTING
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS AND 12
NEW POSITIONS TO CONTINUE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
RADIO INTER INTEROPERABLE SYSTEM
, WHICH IS A STATEWIDE PUBLIC
SAFETY RADIO SYSTEM THAT
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVES
INTEROPERABILITY FOR STATE,
LOCAL AND FEDERAL PUBLIC SAFETY
RESPONDERS. UH, WITH ME, AS YOU
SAID, IS MR COURIER, ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AND
COMMUNICATIONS, AND HE'S GOING
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THE PROPOSAL. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. CHAIR UH, MY NAME IS BUDGE
CURRY. I'M THE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS. AS ERIC SAID, IF
YOU WANT TO THINK OF THIS
PROGRAM WHEN YOU MAKE A 911 CALL
THE 911 SYSTEM GETS YOU TO THE
911 CENTER. THOSE 911 1ST
RESPONDERS. ANSWER YOUR CALL.
PROVIDE THE SERVICES. THE NEXT
STEP THEY DO. THEY DISPATCH
RESOURCES TO WHEREVER YOU ARE TO
HELP YOU, UH, WE USE A COMPUTER
AIDED DISPATCH PROGRAM TO DO
THAT WE RELAY INFORMATION FROM
THE CALLER TO THE FIRST
RESPONDER. WELL, IF YOU'VE EVER
USED YOUR PHONE. YOU KNOW, IT
DOESN'T WORK EVERYWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WHEN YOU CAN'T
RECEIVE THE INFORMATION OVER
THAT MOBILE DISPATCH SYSTEM, THE
RADIO SYSTEM IS HOW YOU RELAY
THAT INFORMATION OUT TO THE
FIRST RESPONDER. SO THE
DISPATCHER IS GETTING
INFORMATION FROM THE 911 CALLER
RELAYING THAT OVER THE RADIO
SYSTEM OUT TO THE FIRST
RESPONDERS IN THE FIELD, SO IT'S
THAT LAST PIECE OF THE PUZZLE
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED THIS
PROGRAM FOUR YEARS AGO, WE
REALLY INTENDED IT TO BE AN
INTEROPERABLE SYSTEM. SO HENCE
THE NAME CHRIS, CALIFORNIA.
INTEROP SYSTEM. IT WAS SO
SUCCESSFUL STATE AGENCIES ARE
NOW COMING TO US SAYING, HEY, WE
WANT TO USE THIS EVERY DAY FOR
OUR DAILY USE. AND THIS IS WHERE
WE CAME UP WITH THIS BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL TO ALLOW US THE
RESOURCES TO BUILD IT OUT, NOT
JUST FOR INTEROPERABLE USES BUT
FOR DAY TO DAY USE, SO THE
REQUEST INCLUDES WHAT WE NEED IN
TERMS OF STAFFING TO BUILD OUT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE, THE SECURITY
REALLY TYING INTO THE
CYBERSECURITY CONVERSATION. YOU
JUST FINISHED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE GOT A DEDICATED SYSTEM
ABLE TO MOVE THAT ALL THE WAY
FROM THAT NEED HELP TO THOSE
THAT ARE PROVIDING HELP HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY DETAILED QUESTIONS.
HELLO. NOTHING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NOTHING ALL RIGHT, UM,
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT, UM, I. I DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF THINGS I JUST
WANTED TO. SO I JUST WANT YOU
GUYS TO BE ON RECORD TO ADDRESS
THIS. THERE ARE SOME
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
THAT LOOK TO NÓ LONGER PROVIDE
SERVICE TO SOME OF THEIR
LANDLINE OR REDUCE SERVICE. IF
YOU WILL, AS LIKE A LAST RESORT.
UM HOW DO YOU SEE THAT IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES. IF YOU KNOW THERE'S
AN EMERGENCY HAPPENING, AND
SOMEBODY'S WANTING TO CALL 911
SO THE CARRIER OF LAST RESORT IS
SORT OF THE TERM THERE. THE èC
PU èC HAS OVERSIGHT OF THAT. OF
COURSE WE ARE ARE INVOLVED IN
THIS BECAUSE, AS YOU SAID, IF
THEY CAN'T CALL 911, THAT
BECOMES A PROBLEM. WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ON THOSE AREAS WHERE, IF
A WIRE LINE CONNECTION IS THE
ABSOLUTE ONLY OPTION? IT'S THOSE
AREAS WERE REALLY ENGAGED WITH
THE PU èC TO MAKE SURE THAT
OPTION REMAINS AVAILABLE, AS YOU
KNOW FROM WHEN THE CARRIER OF
LAST RESORT WAS FIRST PUT PLACE
DECADES AGO. CELL PHONES HAVE
COME ALONG, AS WELL AS BROADBAND
SOLUTIONS THAT PROVIDE A VOICE
OVER IP TYPE CONNECTION. SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT WHERE OUR
MULTIPLE LAYERS OF
COMMUNICATIONS AVAILABLE AND
WHERE DOES IT MAKE SENSE TO
ENSURE THAT THAT DEDICATED WIRE
LINE SERVICE IS STILL AVAILABLE?
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS AGING PAST
END OF LIFE? I MEAN, IT WAS PAST
END OF LIFE 10 YEARS AGO, AND SO
THAT'S REALLY THE CONCERN HERE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE BEST
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE FOR SO THAT
THEY CAN ACCESS THESE SERVICES.
DEFINITELY. AND THE REASON WHY
I'M CONCERNED IS, YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A RURAL
COMMUNITY. UM AND WE ALSO HAVE
OUR AGING POPULATION AS WELL AS,
UM PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND SOCIO-ECONOMIC
STANDINGS AND SO FORTH. SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW, AS THESE CONVERSATIONS OF
CARRIER OF LAST RESORT IS KIND
OF MOVING FORWARD THAT WE
ACTUALLY HEAR SPECIFICALLY FROM
Kò Ó E S¼. UM UH, A POTENTIAL
RECOMMENDATION OR THEY AGREE
WITH THIS OR DO NOT AGREE WITH
THIS, BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THERE'S
A LOT OF MISINFORMATION OUT
THERE. UM AND I DON'T
NECESSARILY REPRESENT A VERY
RURAL COMMUNITIES. IT'S NOT MY
TERRITORY, BUT IT'S SOMETHING
I'M CONCERNED WITH, UM
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
CONSTITUENTS THAT ASK US EVEN
THOUGH OUR TERRITORY IS NOT
NECESSARILY, YOU KNOW, IN THAT
FIELD, RIGHT? SO UM I WOULD LIKE
A VERY PUBLIC YOU KNOW,
COMMENTARY FROM, UH, THE TO, UH,
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES. UM
WHEN THAT CONVERSATION KEEPS
MOVING FORWARD, IF YOU GUYS CAN
PROVIDE THAT, UM OTHER THAN
THAT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS TO ENSURE THAT EVERYONE
HAS A CHANCE TO BE HEARD. PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO 30
SECONDS AND IF SOMEONE ELSE HAS
ALREADY MADE A SIMILAR COMMENT,
PLEASE JUST ADD A ME TOO. THANK
YOU AND LET'S BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENTS. GOOD MORNING, SENATOR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M HERE, UH, TO SPEAK ON ISSUE.
SEVEN ANTHONY DEMARTINO,
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE, CRIME SURVIVORS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. WE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
2022 TO GET THE FUNDING FOR
FLEXIBLE CASH ASSISTANCE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH Kò Ó E S¼ AS
A MEMBER OF THE ADVISORY COUNCIL
. WE ASKED THAT YOU REJECT THE
DELAY IN WORK TO FIND A WAY TO
GET SOME OF THE MONEY OUT THE
DOOR THIS YEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. MOVING ON. UH,
KIMLER IS WITH THE CAL, UH,
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND JUST WANT TO ELEVATE AN
ISSUE AROUND THE LOSS OF VCA
FUNDING THAT IS HAPPENING AND
LOSING SOME OF THE GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT OUR, UM
HOMOS YOUTH ARE VICTIMS OF CRIME
, DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, AS WELL AS
SOME ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
NECESSARY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CRISIS LINE HASN'T RECEIVED AN
INCREASE IN OVER NINE YEARS, AND
IT SERVES OVER 15,000 CALLS,
CHAT IN TEXAS TO OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE, AND WE HAVE OVER 100
VOLUNTEERS, SO WOULD APPRECIATE
SOME ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS, SARA NOCITO ON BEHALF
OF CAL NINA, REPRESENTING OVER
8000, PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHERS
AND PUBLIC SYSTEM PROFESSION.
UH, SYSTEM PROFESSIONALS ACROSS
THE STATE. I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON
ITEM EIGHT. WE UM DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE PROPOSAL.
BUT WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS.
UM, ABOUT THE REDIRECTION OF SET
OF FUNDING. UH FOR, UM, BUILDING
OUT CHRIS AND THE CAPS NET
BECAUSE IT'S REDIRECTING FUNDS
THAT ARE HISTORICALLY USED FOR,
UH, THE ABILITY TO ANSWER 911
CALLS FROM THE NETWORK,
INCLUDING, UH, THE ADOPTION,
ADOPTION AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
NEXT GENERATION 911. WE DO
UNDERSTAND THE BENEFITS OF èC
AND CAPS NET. WE JUST THINK THAT
THOSE SHOULD GO FROM OTHER
PURPOSES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING GEORGE SORES OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION,
SPEAKING ON AN ISSUE NUMBER TWO,
THE FEE INCREASE. I JUST WANTED
TO, UH, NOTE OUR CONCERN AND
THAT WE'RE MONITORING IT TO SEE
IF IT'S A JUSTIFIED AND NEEDED
AT THIS TIME, BUT THAT IS ALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC MEMBERS ARE. ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEEING NONE. THANK YOU.
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY. IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY, PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US,
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY TO THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE PARTICIPATE. EVERYONE'S
PARTICIPATION. WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THAT GENDER FOR TODAY'S HEARING
THE SENATE BUDGET SUBCOMITTEE
NUMBER FIVE ON CORRECTIONS,
PUBLIC SAFETY, JUDICIARY, LABOR
AND TRANSPORTATION. ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU.